(package clunks)
(upbeat music)
(plastic rustling)
- So yeah, this smartwatch is $69.
But, but, before you
type it, is it though?
Is it really that nice?
Is it that good?
I feel like we should define good first,
because going into this, I was thinking,
"Just the fact that you can get
"a fully functioning
smartwatch for $69 in 2023,"
just that by itself, on its
face, was kind of amazing.
'Cause we live in a world
where you can easily spend hundreds
and hundreds of dollars on a smartwatch.
But clearly, there's a wide spectrum
of what these things can be capable of.
So this one, just the simple stuff, right?
Just the basics, the time,
notifications, step counter,
heart rate, calorie
counter, sleep tracking,
just on its face, that's good enough
for 95% of people, right?
Well, let's just start
with the basics here.
This is a square smartwatch.
It's got this orange silicon
band that comes in the box
and it feels surprisingly similar
to any other smartwatch band.
And then it's got a
1.96-inch diagonal display.
The color is metallic gray,
but the material here is
definitely not nearly as metallic.
It does say aluminum alloy on their site,
but if you didn't tell
me that, just holding it,
I would swear this is 100%
made of plastic on the outside.
But, you know, at least it's coated
in sort of a matte finish on the back part
that's touching your wrist
around the heart rate sensors.
And then there's some
engravings with a bunch of text
in the Nothing font, like the model number
and the headquarters location,
which happens to be Cheapside, London,
which is very appropriate.
Honestly, it doesn't
look or feel terrible,
but it just, it clearly has
all the obvious shortcuts
of a cheap product the more
you look closely at it.
You know, the bezels are thick
and also weirdly uneven
all the way around.
There is no rotating dial,
just the single shallow,
cheap feeling button right
above the small tinny speaker
to the side and no fancy
puck to charge, just USBA
to dual pin cable that comes in the box.
It magnetizes to the
back, which in hindsight,
I guess is just as
convenient as a fancy puck,
but, you know, a little
less elegant looking.
But I guess, the key here is
all of it works and it's solid.
Like, the brightness outside,
it gets up to 600 nits.
There's no auto brightness though,
so you gotta change brightness
manually, like this.
But hey, at its max, it's
very good indoors, at least.
And the whole thing is IP68
water and dust resistant,
which is, first of all,
great if you want to go out
and sweat in it or go out in the rain.
But also wasn't there
a long period of time
where OnePlus and Nothing
products didn't get IP certified
'cause it cost too much extra?
But now, the CMF watch has it,
but then it all works with the
CMF Watch app on your phone,
which is where all the data
gets sent via Bluetooth.
So honestly, there's not too
many different clever ways
to design a watch UI,
so, you know, if you get a smart watch,
if you've used one before,
you'll basically already
know how to use this one.
So your watch face is your starting point.
And then you can swipe
through fitness data,
which looks surprisingly
like Apple Watch rings.
It's got your heart rate
history for the past 24 hours.
The weather is there in
that simple dot matrix way,
plus sleep time if you
use it to track sleep,
then a single press on
that plastic feeling button
will take you to your app list,
which you can view as a grid or as a list.
And then there's a good
amount of apps in here
that just come on the watch.
So an exercise app that has
a ton of different exercises,
the blood oxygen app,
which gives you your
measurements whenever you want.
You've also got a phone call app
and yes, you can receive
phone calls on the watch
and that tinny little
speaker will crank out audio
as loud as it can to
facilitate a real conversation.
There's also a music app,
which gives you just music controls
for whenever something
is playing on your phone.
There's even a camera remote app,
which it doesn't actually open
the camera app on my phone
or show a viewfinder preview,
but when I do have the camera app open,
the shutter button does
actually work, so there's that.
There's even a voice assistant app,
which if you open it, basically
just opens Google Assistant
on your phone and then uses the mics
and speakers on the watch
for you to interact with it.
The Find My Phone app is hilarious though.
It only works when the CMF app is open
or running on the phone.
So if you've just closed the app,
it will just ask you to
open the app on your phone,
but you don't have your phone.
But when you do actually open it,
so it plays this max volume ringing sound,
which will allow you to find the phone,
which is pretty cool as long
as you've got that app open
or have opened it recently.
And I will say the UI on the watch itself,
it feels like it's moving
around pretty quickly
and not too much waiting
time to actually open
or switch between these apps,
mostly because they're very lightweight.
Like, this thing is basically
just a Bluetooth accessory,
pinging little controls on your phone
and then it's got watch faces
and the watch faces have
a nice little variety.
I think this one's probably my favorite
with the orange theme
and a second hand moving slowly
in a full circle down here.
I feel like I'm pretty impressed.
It's also very lightweight,
not that people always value
lightweight in watches,
but in this price range,
they're pretty much all
gonna be made of plastic.
So you might as well lean into it.
And this thing is super light,
so if you're doing sports
or just running around, yeah,
it's kind of out of the way.
And then because it's
a Bluetooth accessory
and a pretty generic one,
you can use this actually
with basically any Android phone.
So you just grab the Play
Store app, which has 3.1 stars
and it does have some connection
issues occasionally for me.
But even that sort of
availability, at least,
on any Android phone is
better than Apple can say
about their own smartwatch.
And it gives me all the
basic info I'm looking for
from heart rate history
to workout summaries.
Honestly, it's not so
bad when it's working.
So I'm also able to do sleep tracking,
since that only really requires
the heart rate sensors.
But I also continue to get
that info from the sensors
that are actually built into
the mattress cover I use.
At this point, I'm sure
you've heard of Eight Sleep
and the Pod Mattress Cover
that, you know, warms up
and cools down each side
of the bed independently,
automatically.
So that thing not only
helps you sleep better
by automatically changing
the temperatures,
but then it also monitors how you sleep.
It's got the sensors inside
and then delivers a report for you.
So you just open the app every morning,
you get this personalized report
that shows you things like
your heart rate variance,
respiratory rate, you know,
how your sleep stages
panned out overnight.
So I think I'm officially
done wearing any wearables
to sleep for any sleep tracking data,
just 'cause this handles it all.
Now, I've actually
talked about them before
and I saw a lot of your
comments about Eight Sleep.
And so I chatted with
Eight Sleep about them
and was able to get them to offer
a little bit more functionality
to people who are new,
like, first time signing up.
So they'll actually now,
no matter what your membership level,
they will give you a free
Sleep Report every six months,
so it's not behind any sort of paywall.
So thanks to Eight Sleep
for sponsoring this video.
I'm happy to report that
they're also offering
you guys the largest
discount that they ever have.
So if you wanna check it out,
feel free to check out the
link in the description
and use code MKBHD.
So now that I'm not wearing it to sleep,
I am able to charge the
CMF Watch every night.
Like I said, it's got this
little magnetic pin charger,
technically not as pretty
as those fancy wireless charging pucks,
but honestly, pretty close.
And the battery life, I've
realized, is really, really good
because of how simple it is.
Again, just a Bluetooth accessory,
not a whole ton of
processing power needed.
On their site, they're claiming, like,
13 days of regular use.
I don't know if I'm gonna get that,
but I was able to get three
straight days easy, no problem.
And I'm sure you could
probably use Power Saver mode
and get even more if you wanted to.
So it's got better battery
life than an Apple Watch.
But really, the main thing that I learned,
when testing this watch, is it turns out,
this is actually a pretty
expensive watch in its segment.
$69 is on the premium end
for a very basic smartwatch.
It's actually pretty
common for the cheapest,
most basic smartwatches to
be in the 20 to $50 range.
And, you know, at that point,
they're all, more or
less, the same product.
They're all a simple,
plastic-y Bluetooth accessory
with some slightly different designs.
So this, the CMF Watch Pro is
a slightly better packaged,
slightly better design,
slightly better looking version
for a slightly upcharge,
kind of the same way Nothing
is probably charging a little bit more
than you would expect for a
phone with the same specs,
just 'cause of the design
and the nice stuff they do with it.
That's what this is too.
And I bring up Nothing because CMF
is Nothing's ultra-budget sub-brand
and they actually do some
other stuff, like earphones,
chargers, same deal,
extremely cheap products,
but just marked up a little bit
for nice packaging and nice design.
So here, I'll leave you with this.
CMF, in the industries,
typically stands for color,
material, finish.
It's the name of the company,
but it's also what
those letters stand for.
And the CMF of this smartwatch
is it's very much still
silver-ish, fingerprint-y,
technically metal, but
feels kind of plastic-y.
But if you squint enough,
this square kind of looks
like an Apple Watch Ultra.
And if that's your comparison point,
then this thing is a total bargain.
So I think that was what
their real goal was.
Yeah, if you wanna get one
of these things, you can.
It is maybe a little more
challenging to get it in the U.S.
Maybe if you import it,
spend a couple extra dollars,
then you're competing with
some other smartwatches,
but it's an option.
But now you know it exists.
The more you know.
Thanks for watching, catch you
guys in the next one, peace.
(soft upbeat music)